ministerpräsident beck you for coming to
as danke fürs kommen droht sie haben da
ein bemerkenswertes buch geschrieben und
sie haben ihren lesern versprochen dass
sie sie fühlen lassen erleben lassen wie
es ist präsident zu sein im weißen haus
und das machen sie und sie sind dabei
ziemlich freizügig über all die defizite
und die pannen und frustrationen und
fehler passiert frage ich mich ob sie
nicht besser ein bisschen vorsichtiger
gewesen wären denn so ein bisschen
mysterium ist ja auch ein macht fand in
einer demokratie das ist meine meinung
profitiert jeder von transparenz eine
leistungsfähige demokratie ist
notwendigerweise immer die
zusammenarbeit zwischen den gewählten
und den bürgerinnen und bürgern und wenn
diese nicht gut informiert sind immer
dann wenn sie die regierung als etwas
oft loser distanz wahrnehmen dass auf
sie einwirkt und nicht als etwas in dem
die ein wort mitzusprechen haben ihre
stimme zählt
dann geht es schon los mit dem
zusammenbruch der demokratischen
funktionsweise
ich habe mir daher gesagt das sei für
muss die gelegenheit nun einmal einen
schritt zurück zu machen
es war eine sehr ereignisreiche
präsidentschaft und sie zu beleuchten
und den menschen zu beschreiben wie
entscheidungsprozesse laufen
welche alternativen sich geboten hatten
und wie man entschieden hat die art von
krisen herausforderungen die ich zu
bewältigen hatte waren zwar ganz
erheblich aber wie wir das heute auch
wieder sehen
in dieser jahrhundert pandemie sind das
keine einzigartigen herausforderungen
und probleme und schließlich und
letztlich leben in einer stärkeren
gesellschaft mit einer stärkeren
regierung wenn der bürger informiert ist
wenn man ihr buch ließ dann kommt ein
ständig die frage ist gesa präsidentin
kontrolle über den lauf der zeit oder
wird er getrieben
wenn sie auf diese jahre zurückblicken
war der meer getrieben werden als sie
erwartet hatten
diskussion die ich mit mir selber aus
trage mit meinen leuten und die
historiker sind ganz verrückt nach
dieser frage wie weit war das schicksal
wie weit war dass seine person die gerne
drinnen rom
wie weit ist er da getrieben worden
durch den breiteren wirtschaftlichen
ökologischen gesellschaftlichen strom
der zeit meine antwort ist sowohl als
auch ich beschreibe das auch im buch ich
habe ja nicht mit einem weißen blatt
angefangen
wir hatten schon 180.000 soldaten eben
die rad und in afghanistan waren bereits
voll eingebunden in diese mission al
kaida zu besiegen
und ich habe ein erbe übernommen eines
gesundheitssystems das weitesten
privatwirtschaftlich abgestützt ist und
viele menschen ohne krankenversicherung
dastehen lässt
wir schauen zurück auf ein jahrhundert
in dem die wirtschaft auf autorädern
gerollt ist und mit billigem öl gefahren
ist wenn ich jetzt eine politik gegen
den klimawandel machen wollte oder
sicherstellen wollte dass jeder eine
kranken für sich
oder die kriege eben ausmerzen wollte
dann müsste ich in allen fällen zunächst
einmal mit der vergangenheit umgehen und
ich glaube so wie ich das beschreibe
haben wir da eine regierung die
regierung der usa
die mich an einen ozeandampfer erinnert
das ist kein schnellboot
da kann man am ruder drehen aber nicht
sofort 90 grad nach rechts oder links
abbilden sondern das geht fünf grad
weise in zehn jahren werden sie
vielleicht merken dass jemand ein
bisschen anders gelenkt hat in eine
andere richtung um einen eher
zunehmenden landes zu lösen
wirtschaftliche ungerechtigkeit
ungleichheit fragen der rassen
gerechtigkeit nein dann hoffe ich dass
man in fünf jahren die ersten kleinen
ausschläge sieht und die dinge besser
werden aber wenn wir mitten drin bist
dann fühlt sich das quälend langsam an
und man hat das gefühl dass man dauernd
irgendwelche eisberge rammert lernt sie
all das getan haben wurde irgendwo
irgendwie da draußen im land der boden
bereitet für die enttäuschung die
abgeschlossenheit von menschen die sich
selbst als patriotische religiöse
konservative amerika
wie fühlten sich von ihnen überhaupt
nicht mehr vertreten
das war dann der boden auf dem donald
trumps wahlsieg möglich wurde
wie kann es sein dass sie das dauernd
übersehen haben diesen langsam hoch
kochenden erhöht wir haben das nicht
übersehen
das gab es ja immer schon ich schreibe
das auch im buch das hat sich auch
ausdruck verschaffen aber bevor ich
gewählt wurde gab es bereits newt
gingrich in den vereinigten staaten hat
es immer diese langanhaltende
spannung gegeben zwischen progressiven
kräften unsere musik in richtung aus
eine stärker auf einbeziehung gepolt
gesellschaft berichten die sich
einsetzen für frauen frauen am
arbeitsplatz frauen mit mehr
verantwortung und möglichkeiten und
anerkennung
dann die amerikaner die bürgerrechte von
menschen die nicht weißer hautfarbe sind
und dann haben sie die die ich eine
protektive nennen würde denen es darum
geht die bestehenden hierarchien zu
schützen
die privilegien zu schützen in unserer
gesellschaft und das geht ja nun zurück
auf die frühesten tage unserer nation
denken sie an den bürgerkrieg wurde und
dann die schlachten in den 60er jahren
über bürgerrechte rechte der frauen und
so weiter in diesem sinne muss man sagen
dass diese spannung in amerika immer
vorgelegen gestanden hat jetzt dann
allerdings einen präsidenten zu wählen
der so aussieht wie ich und nicht wie
meine 43 vorgänger das hat das wie unter
einem vergrößerungsglas deutlich werden
lassen und war das bewusst wird hernach
haben sie das genug beachtet das
ergebnis sieht nicht danach aus
der fall zeigt wie man einer vermutung
annahme hat die bedeutet jeder politiker
kontrolliert die nationale psyche zu 100
prozent
das spricht aus ihrer frage wenn sie 400
jahre lang rassen probleme hatten
zerrissenheit
misstraut von beiden seiten das können
sie so schnell nicht mit einer
handbewegung überwinden
kein politiker in keinem land wird
jemals in der lage sein diese dinge
völlig zu entwirren
ein jahrhundert von kultur konflikten
auszulöschen
nein ich glaube der umstand der hier
möglicherweise hinzukam und das ist
nicht spezifisch amerikanisch das haben
sie auch in europa war die finanzkrise
2009 2008 2009 denn sie erhöhte die
instabilität die ängste die sorgen und
solche konflikte werden in der
gesellschaft dann wahrscheinlicher wenn
die menschen sich verunsichert fühlen
wenn sie angst haben es könnte nach
hinten gehen sie könnten zurück
gezwungen werden was die phase ihres
lebens angeht nicht nach vorn und
populistische politiker haben das immer
wieder ausgenutzt in ihren ländern in
mein land dem sie die türkei die
philippinen und ein teil dessen was ich
dagegen wollte in meinem buch ist
einfach das ausmaß in dem wir alle vor
einem ideenwettbewerb auf einbeziehung
angelegte gesellschaft glauben keine
kriege eine reihe von grundsätzen die
universelle art sind und auf der anderen
seite die älteren tradition des stammes
denken dass man sich strukturiert und
organisiert
auf der grundlage eine gleichen religion
eines gleichen aussehens eine gleichen
sprache und sehr oft ist es doch so dass
die politik sich auf starke männer auf
macht verlässt und donald trump
ist von einigen dieser dinge nicht
abgewichen und nehmen die orban in
europa oder erdogan in der türkei oder
auf den philippinen oder putin in
russland da sehen sie solche figuren die
die rückkehr zum alten glanz versprechen
und diese ideen wettstreit hat nicht mit
kant begonnen und auch nicht geendet
aber ich glaube eines unter dem strich
am ende der reise werden wir und meine
politiker die ich vertrete die bessere
geschichte anzubieten haben und jungen
menschen werden die attraktiver finden
als die rückwärts gerichteten
geschichten von menschen wie krampe
hinzu finish der burg seid ihr buch
herauskam ist der sechste januar
passiert der sturm auf das kapitol haben
sie sich so etwas in ihren wildesten
träumen vorstellen können in washington
nein aber überrascht bin ich auch nicht
angesichts des ausmaßes der
empfänglichkeit die dahinter stand dass
es zu diesem aufruf kommen konnte in der
hauptstadt
was mich überrascht hat war eigentlich
wie wenig die polizei die
sicherheitskräfte vorbereitet waren
auf solche vorgänge in der hauptstadt
und das ist immer wieder angemerkt
worden
seit es dazu kam die sichert würden
waren viel besser vorbereitet auf
friedliche proteste
stichwort black leisen meter im letzten
sommer als jetzt auf solche vorgänge in
der hauptstadt
das sagt einiges doch auch über diese
lang anhaltenden fragen probleme im
zusammenhang mit terrassen problematik
in den usa
aber klaus ich habe eines nicht erwähnt
aber im buch tue ich das
das möchte ich noch ansprechen das
aufkommen der rechtsorientierten
sozialen medien in kombination mit
medien wie fox wie sie menschen füttern
mit informationen aus meiner sicht ist
das völlig abgehoben von der
wirklichkeit ist aber angelegt darauf
zorn und hass zu schüren und vorurteile
wo sie sparen vorher ja kurz über die
menschen die möglicherweise angst hatten
nach meiner wahl
angst hatte ich würde mich eher an nicht
annehmen oder sie schauen dauernd fox
fox sagt ihr seitdem wurscht und der ist
auch nicht christlicher überzeugung und
der versucht eure kinder einer
gehirnwäsche zu unterziehen
mit seinen liberalen gedanken
nein das stimmt ja alles gar nicht aber
das war die wirklichkeit wie die
menschen sie wahrgenommen haben anteile
davon was wir jetzt gesehen haben dass
wir beobachten in aller welt
was wir tendenziell als vielleicht höher
entwickelt bessere gesellschaft
wahrnehmen ist genauso anfällig und
verwundbar für fehlinformationen in
ruanda kenia myanmar in aller welt wo
wir konflikte sehen die zu gewalt führen
wenn sie menschen füttern mit lügen
verzerrungen verschwörungstheorien
dann gibt es immer politiker die
versuchen das für sich auszunutzen um
die vorteile zu verschaffen
aber mit der zeit kann da auch das
vertrauen in der gesellschaft zusammen
brechen und zu solchen tragödien führen
kolberg gehen wir mal zurück zwölf jahre
zu diesen jungen präsidenten der mit
hoffnung ich begann
wenn man diese kapitel ihres buches ließ
da wird man den eindruck nicht los dass
dieser präsident schon spürt wie wenig
exekutive erfahrung er hat
er ist der jüngere senator aus illinois
hat erfolgreich wahlkampf gemacht
ziemlich dynamisch aber was ihm fehlt
das ist die erfahrung mit einer großen
organisation
da ist dieses bisschen unsicherheit in
innen- und zur selben zeit müssen sie
ihre autorität beweisen gegenüber dem
kongress siegen über ihren eigenen
erfahrenen generälen und leuten wie
putin erdogan shipping und andere
erinnern sie sich an diese lernkurve
bravo für diese frage sehr interessant
ich will ganz ehrlich antworten
wahrscheinlich hätte ich noch stärker
verunsichert sein müssen als ich es war
ich bin da rein marschiert und vor
selbstbewusstsein strotzend und weiß was
sie zu tun also weiter nein das war
keine falsche forscher oder so etwas
sondern eine der wenigen tagen eines
wahlkampfs in den usa ist fürchterlich
aber ist dass er so lange dauert im
vergleich zu viel kostet endlos und
erschöpfend frustrierend auch diese
wahlkampf ist so etwas wie ein
ausdauertraining hat sich fertig war mit
dem balkan hatte ich eine organisation
unter mir im wert von einer milliarde
dollar mit tausenden mitarbeitern musste
dauernd entscheidungen treffen
und wenn du dann anno der
bundesregierung stets ein ganz anderes
budget und noch mehr tausende von
mitarbeitern
da war ich schon an
entscheidungsprozessen
und ich schreibe das auch im etwas habe
ich vielleicht chronischer weise aus den
augen verloren ist etwas das ich im
wahlkampf am besten beherrscht habe ein
fehler passiert ist und mangelnde
erfahrung in den ersten drei jahren haus
denn da ich so konzentriert auf die
politischen aspekte und auf das
management auf die mechanik der macht
dass ich die facto wirklich vergessen
habe dass die leute von mir eine
geschichte wollten dass sich
kommunizieren musste was wir gerade
taten
wir hatten es mit einem kaputten system
zu tun den eindruck muss man haben
als sie mit dem kongress verhandelten
über ihre gesundheitsreform da haben sie
herausgefunden dass die abgeordneten und
senatoren gegen sie gestimmt haben oder
auch nur die texte zu lesen weil sie
dachten dass es besser wäre sie ihren
job für ihre position und sie wollten in
der nächsten wahl das nicht verlieren
außerdem haben wir sie sehen dass bei
diesen schwierigen themen wie
waffenkontrolle oder freie
universitätsausbildung oder
gesundheitsreform große mehrheit in der
bevölkerung auf ihrer seite sind und
trotzdem wird das nicht gesetzt das ist
doch wohl ein kaputtes ist ein heute
würde ich diese aussage hier
unterschreiben
das funktioniert nicht man sieht das
jetzt hier sehr schön andere sich der
amtsübernahme durch joe biden mit der
sehr geringen mehrheit der demokraten im
kongress
da erkennt man wie schwer es ist eine
funktionierende gesetzgebung und
regierung
in gang zu setzen es gibt usa
spezifische dinge die eigentlich der
mehrheit entgegenwirken nehmen sie den
senat
das ist kein mehr als gremium
kalifornien das und zwei senatoren
ebenso wie honig mit einer halben
million einwohner vergrößert wurde das
problem noch durch eine art
gewohnheitsrecht ich nicht in der
verfassung steht aber eine praxis
geworden ist mit der sie jede praxis
blockieren können das sogenannte
filibuster sie brauchen heute eine super
mehrheit um irgendein gesetz
durchzubringen die opposition kann jede
initiative stoppen blockieren wenn sie
nicht einverstanden ist oder weil sie
nicht wollen dass der präsident stark
aussieht weil er von der anderen seite
kommt struktur eine veränderung sind
unerlässlich aber was ich vorher
ansprach was ich als präsident gelernt
habe ist dass die politik als solche
wichtig ist aber sie oft eben für uns
ein schimpfwort ist schlecht produziert
politik wohl verstanden soll
kommunizieren verbindung zur
öffentlichkeit herzustellen beschreibend
erläutern was passiert im leben der
menschen
und wenn sie sich zusammentun wie sehen
sie die welt verbessern können und in
meinen ersten 28 jahren
ich spreche darüber ja auch im buch war
ich immer sehr stolz auf meine
entscheidung unsere arbeit unsere
politik aber politisch haben wir an
boden verloren weil ich die geschichte
nicht erzählt habe ich jetzt erzählen
muss ich war dabei
ich kam zu einer zeit ins amt als es der
wirtschaft noch nicht so gut ging die
finanzkrise war akut zwar überwunden
aber die arbeitslosigkeit um die
wirtschaftlichen probleme waren immer
noch ganz oben
das glück ist genauso wichtig wie eine
gute politik aber dann hatte donald
trump offenbar die bessere erzählung
oder er hat sie das rübergebracht
jedenfalls hat er eine große mächtige
bewegung geschaffen und ihm ist es
gelungen den kurs des landes ganz
schnell
also es ja auch nicht wie er gewählt
worden nicht nur wiedergewählt
ab 1 zweitens seine zustimmungsraten
waren zu keinem zeitpunkt so hoch wie
meine am tiefpunkt
selbst wenn er an seinen höchsten punkt
nein wir neigen dazu da gewisse der zone
zu überschätzen
vielleicht den einfluss den er im
vergleich mit dem was wir in acht jahren
zustande gebracht haben
20 millionen menschen haben immer noch
ihrer krankenversicherung obwohl er
versprochen hat die in die tonne zu
treten
denn das was wir im zusammenhang mit
sauberer in der gemacht haben
kohlenstoff emissionen soweit das geht
immer noch unter und tackern beiden
wieder einsteigen unabhängig von allem
was er dazu zu kommentieren hatte
nein querbeet muss ich sagen die
fortschritte sind nicht wieder
zerpflückt worden
die wir erzielt haben die wir gesetzt
haben nur haben wir eben nicht die
auflösung gesehen dieser diskussion die
wir in der ganzen welt beobachten mieten
in den feindlichen staaten diskussion zu
dem thema wie schaffen wir es in einer
globalisierten welt zu leben mit den
unterschiedlichsten menschen und
auffassungen mit einer absoluten
informations overkill
wie können wir märkte
wie können so bessere ergebnisse für
mehr menschen erreichen
wie können wir lernen miteinander zu
leben
auf eine art und weise die auf
kooperation angelegt ist in nicht auf
konflikte und ich glaube da gibt es noch
eine menge zu tun der progressiven seite
auf der linken oder mitte links um
einige der anhaltenden probleme und
herausforderungen zu bewältigen
herausforderung durch die rechte auch am
ende glaube ich werden wir die besseren
antworten habe das bessere produkt
anzubieten haben aber wir müssen in der
lage sein das auch richtig an den markt
zu bringen
lassen sie uns mal für einen moment über
die macht des präsidenten reden wir
sagen ja immer der amerikanische
präsident sei der mächtigste mensch der
welt und dann waren sie nicht mal in der
lage das gefängnis von guantanamo zu
schließen
das ist eine militäreinrichtung und sie
sind der oberkommandierende und sie
können es nicht schließen
wie viel macht haben sie dann überhaupt
denn in der gesellschaft und auch in
ihrer regierung in fragen so umstritten
so many konflikt in köln bot in die
administration and inside
beides kann gleichzeitig war sein und zu
treffen wenn es dort irgendwo auf der
welt eine krise
dann rufen wir leute immer noch in
washington dc haben nicht den peking und
auch nicht in moskau und neu delhi
denn egal ob eine naturkatastrophe
darüber rede ich im buch nicht aber
möglicherweise im nächsten band dann
gehe ich darauf ein dann müssen die usa
die welt mobilisieren um schnell und
wirksam zu reagieren
selbst unsere kritiker wenn nicht gar
unsere feinde erwarten von uns dass wir
dann helfen eine tagesordnung
aufzustellen und eine internationale
reaktion zu inszenieren wenn es darum
geht zum beispiel das weltfinanzsystem
den welthandel zu gestalten oder
umzugehen mit einer nationalen
sicherheits problematik in diesem sinne
muss sagen was der us-präsident tut hat
nach wie vor eine ungeheure auswirkung
teilweise auch weil die regierung der
usa über eine handbreite verfügte sie
irgendwo auf der welt haben diplomaten
militärische fähigkeiten institutionelle
erfahrungen die weltweit wirken können
sodass selbst großmächte wie ich davon
noch weit entfernt sind
das mag in 50 jahren anders sein ist
aber heute so aber ein etwas anderes
trifft auch der einzelne us präsident
als kann nur so leistungsfähig sein wie
seine oder irgendwann vielleicht mal
ihre fähigkeit entwickelt ist den
kongress mitzunehmen zu mobilisieren in
zahllosen fragen auch fragen wie
guantánamo wo man sagen würde das war
doch eigentlich etwas für den
oberbefehlshaber
nein denn der gesetzgebungsprozess
unterbrochen wird wenn der kongress
nicht funktioniert dann führt das dazu
dass die exekutive eine zwangsjacke
verpasst gekommen oder angeklagt wird
und sich nicht mehr bewegen kann
das ist das problem das wird kein reines
parlamentarisches system haben die beste
plattform
der welt in den vereinigten staaten aber
sie brauchen den kongress der unabhängig
von ihnen gewählt wird und einen seite
bedingt dass eine gewisse stabilität
denn ob ich es bin oder donald trump
keiner von uns kann praktisch aus dem
stand seine tagesordnung durchsetzen
das bedeutet aber dass in fragen wie den
klimawandel manchmal schnelle bewegung
notwendig sind und durchgreifende dinge
und da wird es schwierig die
bundesregierung der feindlichen staaten
ist nicht in der lage schnell genug zu
reagieren und das ist etwas wo ich hoffe
dass man etwas tun wird
man kann da etwas tun aber dass der ziel
anstrengungen erfordern
lassen sie mich zu einem punkt in ihrem
buch kommen der mich besonders berührt
hat
es geht darum die geschichte eines
amerikanischen frachters der von
somalischen piraten gekapert wurde
junge branche 20 oder so und am ende
haben sie sie erschießen das durch
sonderkommandos und damit diesen
berühmten kapitän phillips in ihrem buch
denken sie darüber nach dass diese
jungen leute keine hoffnung hatten keine
aussicht auf ziehung einkommen um eine
familie oder sie schreiben darüber wie
gerne sie geholfen diesen kids eine
zukunft zu geben und dann sagen sie so
wie die welt ist und so wie die
maschinerie ist die ich kombiniere habe
ich sie umbringen lassen statt ihnen zu
helfen
das zeigt mir das dilemma ihres
charakters
sie wollten die welt besser machen und
dann sind sie verantwortlich für ein
kapitel das alles andere wie gehen sie
damit um
da haben sie völlig recht
das war einerseits schon absicht diesen
widerspruch transparent zu machen
ein widerspruch
denen versucht habe aufzulösen in der
nobelpreisrede die ich in oslo gehalten
habe sie nehmen ihr wann diese ungeheure
macht an starten sich mit ihr aus wir
gehen nicht mit dem leeren blatt sie
haben die welt wie sie gerne hätten und
die welt wie sie ist und sie müssen
diese dinge in einklang bringen beide
welten miteinander versöhnen ich hatte
nicht den luxus haben das auch nicht
geleistet echte bedrohungen wie al qaida
oder den islamischen staat zu ignorieren
um die vereinigten staaten unsere
menschen unsere verbindungen zu schützen
gab es augenblicke wo ich gebe dir et
maschinerie anleihe musste anweisung
geben musste mit diesen terroristen
organisationen hinzugehen und doch mein
tiefstes bedürfnisse grund warum ich
mich beworben habe als präsident ist
nicht konflikte zu beginnen wurde mich
hinein zu begeben sondern zu explorieren
ob und was ich hier liefern kann bildung
erziehung für kinder zu essen für die
hungrigen obdach für die obdachlosen das
war das bedürfnis und irgendwann stellen
sie dann fest wie sie versuchen die welt
ein bisschen in die richtige richtung
und zu manövrieren aber trotzdem den
prozess im griff zu behalten
fertig zu der trotz hässlicher und
trauriger realitäten die sie im alltag
antreffen und dem kann man entrinnen
es gab doch augenblicke ich versuche das
im buch auch zu beschreiben in denen man
denkt das ist nicht immer nur kritik von
rechts die dich frustriert sondern auch
kritik von links deren
werte details die aber den luxus haben
dass sie hier mit diesen entscheidungen
nicht umgehen müssen und die so tun
können als gäbe es keine widersprüche
vielleicht sagen wir müssen das völlig
auseinander nehmen und anders machen
liegt mit diesem komplex aus militär und
geheimdiensten den wird putz aufgebaut
hatten ein al qaida ist ja immer noch da
und die auf der linken wollen immer noch
nicht dass man ihren wohnblock in die
luft sprengt ein zorniger junger mann
oder so im idealfall nicht vor solchen
entscheidung stehen möchten habe ich
mich immer wieder in solchen situationen
befunden
und das meine ich eben ganz genau wenn
ich sage die hatte chivu muss den kurs
halten das ziel im auge behalten als
auch zu erkennen woher du kommst wenn du
etwas bewirken willst wenn du lediglich
reagiert auf das widmung das jetzt dann
wirst du zum zyniker ohne jede vision
und kein land in der welt kommt voran
alle entwickeln sich zurück wenn du aber
immer im auge hass und immer darüber
nachdenkst was möglich ist aber nicht
verstehst von der wirklichkeit bist du
nicht leistungsfähig genug als
frühmorgens der anruf kam mit dem
friedensnobelpreis da hat ihre frau
michelle kurz gesagt wunderbar hanni und
schlief wieder ein und ihre erste frage
war wo für die york post campbells vor
und im grunde ist das bis jetzt eine
unbeantwortete fragen
ich schreibe ich
das nobelkomitee
das ist meine einschätzung wollte mir
das auch ein bisschen als chef auf die
zukunft geben
es standen noch zwischen 2 ich war noch
nicht an meinen zielen angelangt habe
sie haben wahrscheinlich erkannt dass
der gedanke den amerika im besten falle
vertritt immer noch wichtig ist für die
welt und ein ideal und die arbeit die
ich versuchte zu leisten um die turn
waffenarsenale abzubauen um mit dem
klimawandel ernsthaft umzugehen und der
ehrliche makler zu sein der kriege
vermeidet um sicherzustellen dass der
iran sich nicht nuklear bewaffnet all
diese themen und fragen glaube ich haben
eine wichtige rolle gespielt und man
wollte das komitee wollte den preis
einsetzen als einen klaps auf die
schulter aber ich habe das schon als
verfrüht gesehen und hat mir politisch
zu hause mehr probleme bereitet als
vorteil geboten aber jetzt nach acht
jahren mit dem pariser abkommen und dem
kernwaffen dem mit iran und den new
start vertrag mit russland und einigen
anderen dingen bin ich doch zu der
überlegung gekommen dass das gar nicht
so störend war und dass ich doch
vielleicht nicht ganz zu unrecht gedacht
habe junge das hast du gar nicht so
schlecht gemacht
aber eins klaus eines kann ich wirklich
sagen
und darum geht es unter dem strich mehr
kannst du nicht erwarten und wünschen
wenn du dieses amt bekleidet am ende
lässt sie sich nicht leugnen dass sowohl
die vereinigten staaten von amerika als
auch die ganze welt in einer besseren
verfassung da stand und
mehr hoffnung in sich tragen als ich
ging im vergleich mit der zeit als ich
anfing ich bezeichne die präsidentschaft
als staffelrennen du nimmst den stab du
machst deine strecke über gibst du weißt
nicht wie das rennen enden wird
aber ich kann sagen dass letztendlich
doch paar schritte nach vorn gekommen
bin den staffelstab nach vorne bewegt
der zeit meiner präsidentschaft
präsident dankeschön und jetzt lassen
wir sie arbeiten
zweiter band